yes car tester honey left stick observes
that Kia too is writing the SUV waive
the stomach is Kia's fourth SUV as a
subcompact crossover
this new one is meant to appeal mainly
to young buyers the Koreans have gone
all out with this little SUV the
stomach's lifestyle factor is calculated
to lure buyers away from the rinoa Cup
tour and the pre-show 2008 the message
is simple the mini SUV can take the
place of a compact station wagon or van
the stunning features the popular high
seat position coveted SUV look and
relatively generous space brownie notes
that the stomach has the Kia Rios
platform and interior which means Kia
has succeeded in putting a low weight
crossover on the market depending on the
engine the vehicle weighs between 1145
and 1349 kilos less weight on the front
axle means better feedback from the
suspension and more agility on the road
the 1-liter 3-cylinder turbocharged
engine we tested achieved 88 kilowatts
and serves the 1.2 tonne stomach very
well a top speed of 185 km/h is more
than sufficient for a subcompact SUV its
average fuel consumption it's rated at 5
liters per 100 kilometers but 3 cylinder
engines can never be really quiet and
the kia stomach is no exception the
Asian design team led by veteran German
automotive designer Peter Schreyer
tailored a body for the just 4.1 4 meter
stomach that's not so very different
from any other sub compact SUVs yet it
still features a number of eye catchers
[Music]
the cockpit amounts to a well-organized
workspace with a touchscreen mounted
front and center the materials and
workmanship are quite solid basic
equipment on the stomach includes the
infotainment system with apple carplay
and android auto and of course air
conditioning
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
with volumes ranging from 352 to 1155
liters the luggage space is average for
the class folding the rear seats down
gives you a flat slightly inclined load
bed for an even classier look a two-ton
color scheme is optional Kia has never
been this customizable before at least
on the exterior
[Music]
the stomach is a cool smart SUV with the
right proportions and design all around
the subcompact crossover with the 62
kilowatt 1.2 liter engine starts at
fifteen thousand seven hundred ninety
euros in Germany the 1 liter
turbocharged version we tested lists 420
1890 euros
[Music]
thus constant Ronnie concludes the Kia's
SUV and crossover family's smallest
members brimming with self-confidence
the choice of 29 single and two-tone
paints three interior color schemes and
four equipment packages definitely has
something for everyone